trabalhado pelo propagação do ensino
artístico contemporâneo e pelo
reconhecimento cultural de instrumentos
não eruditos como a guitarra elétrica
joão carlos ramalheiro é professor de
música e propõe pensarmos só saiu do box
é um prazer muito grande poder estar
aqui hoje não cheguei a casa da mulher
sou professora de educação musical
compositor e sócia-diretora empresas
o título da música moderna em arte
hoje é facto partilhar convosco a minha
pergunta é uma história a minha história
mostrar como foi possível pensar fora da
caixa em sala de aula no contexto
escolar muitas vezes é difícil nós temos
um pensamento divergente
vou com uma pergunta
os jovens sabem o querem ser daqui a uns
anos na vida provavelmente aquela
geração não sair do governo podem ser
tudo na vida
cientistas podem ser vistas não permitam
é que exista alguém nas vossas vidas que
não tem limites e devem se manter assim
é isso que os alunos diariamente no
trabalho
tecnicamente aparecem em programas
televisivos como agora o fator x tem
dois alunos com quem desenvolveu um
projeto que trouxe portugal a um prêmio
mundial
vamos começar do início podem ver aqui
todos os anos quando tinham aterrado
seis sete oito anos não sabiam
propriamente o que significava ser
empreendedor não era um amor uma grande
paixão por alguma coisa influenciar o
que significa certamente habilitações
alguns deus quebraram ou interromperam a
faculdade é o caso de alguns tiveram
grandes problemas na escola
um trabalho específico específica um
profissional específica em várias áreas
várias maneiras tempo e dinheiro por
aberta problemas sobretudo criam
soluções e isso é muito importante mas
uma característica e o início para o
chamado big bang ao empreendedorismo é
um momento bom com 99 eu tomei uma
decisão natural hoje os pais tinham
emigrado em 75 amanhã língua materna é o
próprio língua e que o 12º minha família
um propósito e superior
no meu caso era a música ricas ao
sistema em 2006
sobre educação de coimbra e possui muito
cedo que era muito importante contar
histórias que saber quantas histórias
principalmente no ensino do ensino
básico mas isso não é propriamente
inovador em 2010
foi quando eu tive um quadro interativo
na sala de aula e crianças com muitas
expectativas como vamos pular dia nós
temos uma galinha como é que vamos
trabalhar com eles havia um problema
muito grande
falta informação e ferramentas e
conteúdos digitais que era um pouco
consistentes pouca 401 um grande
problema
estava como estava na hora a marcar a
diferença sobretudo por contar histórias
livramento para o mundo virtual as
crianças querem ouvir boas histórias
elas estão expostas gostosas em cinema e
vídeo jogos e é também por essa razão
que leva cada vez mais crianças pularem
jogos então jogar com os professores
estão cada vez mais a despertar para
essa realidade e utilizar isso em sala
de aula
foca esta é mais um lado esquerdo das
nossas mentes é um sucesso
principalmente levados motivação
principalmente quando é visto com muita
freqüência direito nós temos também
simboliza o ao curioso a vontade de
voltar a tentar voltar a tentar portanto
não é isso que nossa sociedade precisa
eu estava convencido de que não vá por
aí e unificação ao lado da escola não
podia virar costas
a evolução e é importante encontrar um
equilíbrio saudável
dentro vive ao jogo e software para
professores e sobretudo queria usar a
criatividade dos alunos
e foi assim que nós criamos o conceito
por ato infracional de volta à família
viajou por outro lado um software de
gestão para os criava em sala de aula
porque utilizar crianças do primeiro
ciclo para este crianças têm uma
capacidade incrível aprendendo ao longo
dos anos que é ser criativo e tudo
começou com uma simples pergunta - mas
veja viabilizam o mundo da música e eles
começaram a pintar pintura musical no
fundo passaram sem treinar ser designer
software desenvolver um conceito
software papel depois posteriormente
utilizamos o pai em tramitação
depois é uma plataforma como acesse
dinâmica várias atividades powerpoint
o powerpoint e assim podemos ter acesso
aos nossos próprios editores permite-nos
tivemos o privilégio de quem não sabe é
uma câmera detecta os nossos movimentos
nós podemos interagir com o computador
os resultados foram incríveis sobretudo
aprender conteúdos da música muito muito
chato muito difícil
a música tem um aproveitamento subiu
principalmente aprender flauta na
leitura
articule minas só no mal surgiu outra
evidência marcou por completa minha
carreira foi a microsoft microsoft
apareceu num momento importante da minha
vida porque por os professores e vocês
são carros de pessoas aqui na platéia
estamos a passar uma fase muito difícil
mas a microsoft fez com que a
conferência por outro lado é uma
competição emprestou inovadores em todo
o mundo chamado toque na semana
não podem imaginar isso o fator x
professor jim dolan eo resultado foi
incrível um segundo lugar no europeu um
primeiro lugar no mundial
vejo que isto foi importante
alimentou é a minha vontade de continuar
em frente
vv manter o espírito empreendedor e para
assumir um risco
estou a trabalhar com jovens estagiários
são jovens com muita criatividade o
mesmo sonho queremos comprometer com a
educação que queremos queremos entregar
material cuidar da minha pedagógico
agora em música e em outras áreas
queremos levar o entretenimento para a
sala da aula muito importante criar
sorriso enquanto estamos a aprender
essa é nossa filosofia só para finalizar
estes jovens estão aqui não perde a fé
em você as nossas capacidades pois estão
altamente importante nessas sociedades
marca a diferença
obrigado
o momento do céu x comedy club executar
salas